I love my child,
I love my mother so much that I couldn't
survive if anything happened to them.
It's like you have some serious thinking
to do about that.
It's like you really want to curse
someone with that kind of love.
Do you?
I couldn't live without you.
It's like,
oh my God,
get away from me.
Really?
It's terrible.
That's the oedipal mother.
That's like,
I'll forgive you.
No matter what you do.
It's like,
really?
He,
no matter what I do a.
You are not my friend.
That's for sure.
Not at all.
It's a horrible thing to do to someone
that's,
that's the witch in the Hansel and
Gretel story,
all gingerbread and outside to the last
kid inside.
You feed them candy and make them fat
and eat them.
Right?
That's Hansel and Gretel.
That's the oedipal mother.
That's one of Freud's major discoveries
if gets a major discovery.
It's like the devouring force of love.
You want the person to be able to stand
on their own and the price you pay for
that is that you stand on your own.
It's like good to have you around.
Glad you're here,
but if,
if,
if tragedies when and if and when
tragedy strikes either of us,
I hope that one of us is standing when
it blows past and that there's a
harshness about that.
That's unbelievably cruel because you
know,
you say,
well,
if my mother died,
I could live.
What,
what kind of monster are you?
Exactly you the death of your mother
doesn't do you in.
Well,
it turns out that being a monster is the
right thing.
So,
and that's a rough thing to learn,
but it's necessary necessarily learn,
you know,
because it also makes you,
at some point,
for example,
as you get older,
by the time you're in your mid twenties,
something like that,
you should start having a relationship
with your parents.
That's approximately one of peers and
you can tell if you have that.
So here's a little trick you can use.
So you have parents,
obviously they have friends,
you probably care what your parents
think.
I would imagine.
Do you care what their friends think of
you?
And the answer to that is,
well,
not nearly as much.
And so then I would say,
well,
why do you care what your parents think
of you?
Then they're the same people.
You know what I mean?
It's just luck of the draw that your
parents or someone else's kids,
friends,
they don't think the same way about them
that you do.
Well,
that's where you see that you have a
projection,
right?
If by the time you're 30,
if what your parents think of you
matters more than what,
say a random set of their friends.
Think of you,
then you've still got your parents
confused with with God.
That's one way of looking at it.
You've still got them confused with an
archetype and you're still a child and
you might think,
well,
it's pretty damn rude not to think about
what your parents think of you anymore.
Not to care.
It's like,
yeah,
it's kind of rude,
but maybe you'll be useful for them when
they get old.
And that's a much better form of caring.
It's like you're going to be independent
enough and strong enough and and
detached enough so that when the,
when the,
when the power dynamic shifts,
which it will,
that you'll be the person that can carry
things forward.
Well,
you can't do a better thing for them
than that.
Right?
That's the best of all possible outcomes
for your parents.